Hello, everybody
My name is Markiplier and welcome back to crash Bandicoot now if you're seeing this and you're wondering, "hey part two
What the hell happened to part one?" then you didn't see my livestream, or you didn't see the archive of it
I'll put a link in the description below. I was playing this game for about two hours and in those two hours
I practically lost my mind, and I don't even know how this game
isn't that difficult but I say that now and I'm going to dive back into it exactly where I left off
But that does not mean... that I'm not going to lose my mind again. So let's get back into it, shall we?
"The Wumpa Islands"
[groans]
Gotta get back into the wumpa fruit, but I feel relaxed I feel a lot better now
I feel like a lot of this game is
compounding stress, and you get flustered as time goes on and you start to lose your skill
So I'm just going to dive right back into it. I've never finished this game
I never even played this game as a kid as I mentioned in the livestream, but now that I'm playing it again. I can see
What the appeal would have been
it's kind of like, uh, Lion King for the Super Nintendo. Just really precise jumping, all the time.
[sniffs]
Ah, ack! Somethin' in my nose. Okay.
What's to the left?
Nothing! You gotta-
Alright. I'm not stupid there, that looked like there was something to the-alright, here we go.
Hoop! Yoop!
Ohhkay
I didn't realize you were enemies because I've never seen you before so - GAH!
Ohhh....
Was that a game over?!
[Uka Uka: "GAME OVER"]
I just got back!
Alright fine. It's fine. It's fine. Let's call Mulligan on that one
let's just say that was for practice and getting back into the swing of things and now it's going to commit
Okay, take two. I'm really not that bad anyone that was watching in the livestream knows that
I actually wasn't doing that terribly in this. I wasn't getting all the prizes mind you-
Heughh!
But I - whoa hey
Alright - but I wasn't doing the worst in the world. I bet if you spin against me, you're gonna die-
Ooh! Yeugh!
I hate that I hate that I hate that!
Huh?
Okay, good
So what's - oh the cold ones are fine? They don't cold me to dea- HAAAAH Okay.
My wampa man is gone
But I've still got dreams. Oh boy...
Okay. Again, I don't know what that does!
Don't know why that is or why that does but why'd you give me so many question blocks?
Huh-huh-huh-huh
Heh, hyee - boosh. Okay.
It seems relatively easy coming back into the swing of things considering what I just came from which is a whole lot of hell
So maybe it's just serving as an intro, but if I jump on you don't you die?!
Oh crap
Right as soon as I say [mock] "ugh, something's easy," [mutters]
Okay, those die if you jump on 'em, these'll die...
This'll die...
Whoomp! I should have hotten that blocks!
HY-UGH!
okay
Lot of this game just comes down to patience, which I don't have any
OF! I made a bad MOVE!
I'm fine cool. Great ah
ah...oh...
HRGH!
What's wrong with me? Aye yai yai. yeah. Okay, we're fine.
Doodly do!
Doodly do! Okay! Doing..  alright.. so far so goo. Back to this part
which should have been the easy part just get apples and then go!
Wrong, we'll be trying to over complicate it with my bullshit
Hee-ya-dee-dah-dee! Okay Huh. Frick-a-dick.
Okay, get over there. HURGH!
Okay. I'm on. BREAAUGH!
Just as a safety precaution
I'm not gonna assume that anything can be jumped on! and I'M ALWAYS GOING TO SPIN NO MATTER WHAT I DO!
Oh not for you though. Hee-yeigh. Alright!
What is that? HEY! UGH!
Okay, ha... you almost made me miss the goddamn checkpoint you son of a byeah-yutch
But I ain't gonna be thwarted that badly no okay. noo! ok.
not today
Okay, my Wampa went away. Oh, I don't like that
heeeeeyyyy
Okay
Got two of those which means the bonus is going to be happening  soon enough. Oh my God. Haha, okay
Like I didn't want to go . Alright what else.....
Ahhh!!!...
I didn't know there was gonna be a steammm vent how was I supposed to know. I jumped on that Befor the whomper guy?
Oh, that's right. Dude.
I don't even know if the wampa guy is the right name for that guy, but I don't even care at this point
I'm gonna name people, whatever guttural song....
Forgot that guy can't die. I don't have my whamp
I'm a game over on it. Oh, I'm in a hurry! why am I in a hurry?! Hurry always gets me dead..
Okay, so I think I got to go under
you
ha
Ha ha ha oh he hi, hi ho d ho haw-dee
I got this. geoo geoo.
Okay
So, just don't get blasted in the asses by the steamy.  ooh boy (grunts). okay,  so far.. ohh..
oh, NOOO!!!!!
God dammit. I didn't know it was the steam ah ah
ah
Speed run pull well why do I always shout speed run right before I do horribly?
Oh, no, I've got ambitions. No reason to continue going anywhere. Oh my God. I thought I was going to die
Look at this learning experience from patients, huh, man you think that I wouldn't... I see you
You can't hide from me. I know you're trying to hide (grunts)
Brrrr, get me over there okay? Huh? Hai-yah! Give me the bonus baby! Please give me the bonus you may be my sister
I'm not a hundred percent sure on the dynamics here
huh, two three four
Oink! doink! doink!
One, one, two three four point one two three four doink! One, two three four point one two three four, doink!
I am going to get this one just in case
doink oink doink
One two three four
One Oink, Oink Oink, Oink Oink oink
oink one two three four five! YAY
Do I not get any lives for that, are you kidding me?! I don't get any lives
But those are what I need
Oh Boy, alright. Fine, man. It'll be that way. That's it that better be it
Teleporter some sorth oh haha
You need to go forward. I forgot about that
I forgot about the lateral motion in this how could I ever get oh boy just looks precise, uh-huh oh?
okay, wait patiently for the scheme and then go ah
Just landed I'm gonna blast anybody don't watch it. Yes, I got a checkpoint
Oh that was farther forward than I thought it was I think it was very forgiving me on me on that one
Can you come back here you do these little bitch? Yeah, I got patients right I can wait all day
baby all
I guess I could have gotten that without you ahah
I didn't know that I didn't even try uh
How would I have know unless I tried. Uh I keep flipping th. ohh... I don't like the look at this
Uh-huh, I didn't like that
Looks like it might have bounced me up into goop and I don't like goop
As much as the internet might say otherwise I like... I don't I don't like goop
Ay yeah! are you okay? Okay? Okay? Okay? All right got it nailed it got it. Did it good
You okay give me some of you?
Toss me. Oh I see what you're doing. Oh, I see what you're doing okay? Oh, not yeah
Okay, here we go
Poink all right. I don't know where I was supposed to get another one of you bastards
I don't even know if there's any secret areas ever
I don't even know secret areas exist
In the world all I know is that this game is the son of a bitch, and I don't like it
yeah, okay, so that's same good, ooh ah
Heyo, I need all the apples I can get please oh
Yeah, all right. Oh, that's a life. I want it. I need a lot. I need a life man
I'm really losing everything on this playthrough here
My pride my joy my life everything pretty much. Oh
triple lives
Why are you? Why are you loading me up for something? It seems like there might be failure in my future. Oh
No, just a reward you never get just rewarded for anything. Oh boy here. We go ow ow
ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow
That wasn't so bad the box that broke the Fox...  the Bandicoot his name is Bandicoot not the Fox...
What's a bandicoot anyway? I have no idea, but we made it through that one okay. We did all right
Let's get through another one without too much trouble cuz I don't know how long this game actually is in total
But I mean, it's part of the trilogy. I don't think I'm going to play all all the games
I'm barely able to get through the the first one with my sanity intact in fact
I may still lose it by the end of this, but I just want to know I just want to know I
Want to know how much farther I have to go because if I'm not even halfway through this and it only gets harder from here
oh
Hey, Cortex power
Ok this cortex the guy that I'm gone. Oh, it's one of the running ones
Alright, I'm ready when am I going to be riding this time the hog that oh no?
I'm not going to be running at all. I thought I was going to be you okay. Oh, boy
I don't like that ah I don't like that. Was that about to kill me? Oh
What kind of power plant is this?! Oh, I should have jumped on that shouldn't I oh okay. That was close. It seems like a
mistake
Oh this seems like a mistake. I shoulda gone the other way. I was led. I was tempted ah. NOO!!
Ohh... Thought I was going to die.
Okay
All right, that's a weird diagonal. Yo, you know
It seems like it's just workplace hazards if all these electrical bolts are just dancing around
I mean this thing doesn't maintain itself so I gotta imagine there's something going on here
Well go left .... alright? AHHH
Okay, that works too. That's an option that I did and had oh thank you for that almost spun that into oblivion
Oh, take it. What is this secret?
Okay, never mind. I don't want to be there. Oh, I should probably go that way I
Don't know where this leads, but okay
(grunts) ok I dont know where I.... woah
wear ( sounds ) I don't wnna
How do you.... I can't do that I?
I don't understand this must be just one of the other ways to go around oh
Okay, let's just keep going ah checkpoint me. Thank you
At least this ain't as bad as the frag no I
spoke too soon ah
Heheheha
Ah..that's funny. That's funny. Can you tell by how I'm laughing now? How about that? That is funny?
Okay
Brewski oh
What is the point is bullshit? Where's the point is? What is this who made this?
Is oh yeah, yeah, let's let's go with this one. All right sure
Hey boink, okay barely made through that all right. What do we got here?
Oh, but who why am I okay sure? You know? What's sure hey, Eddie do
point
You know I got to feel like I'm the asshole here because whoo oh
That easy huh I bet there was some secrets in this level because it doesn't seem like something that would just give it up that
easily
You know what I mean, and I don't even know what I mean there. Whatever. It's fine
All right, huh?
Okay
That is key
when I went through
Relatively easily. I know I didn't get all the I
It's hardly missing him if you've bash him on the head anyway
Okay, I'm beryl I've been stuck in this factory for 13 years. I'm in the generator room
Why why am I destroying everything that I see his?
Experimentation drove me wild, and I just went crazy all over his technology went back to the day oh, hi. How's it going there, buddy?
You look good nice gift
All right, this looks like hell. Oh
I'm gonna get it okay good for me. I don't know why I got it
Great. What was the point of that uh yeah?  Ay yeah, okay? Here we go ah
Yeeaargh why are you doing this to me? Yes?
Righty-ho then ah
Fun,(grunts) I hate you, all right you
geoo, geoo, whoa?!
Geoo. I don't know what you do okay, ah
Thank you. Thanks for coming back for me. Oh
Right got one you know which one. I really go this way. Why do I want to go this way?
All right, cool
I didn't want to go this way plenty of bonuses then smack a wampum root out of the way who needs it.
uh oh uh oh uh oh !!
ooo...Okay. AHHH NOOO!!!
oh
God the ladder
Emotion oh, I made it all the way back here. Now is me being stupid here. We go. I?
oh I guess
AHH Nooo!!!!!
I Hate this oh
Got an achievement. I see london I see france crash Bandicoot is Dead
That's haha.. That's the end of that achievement. Oh
Ay Yea
Some doesn't got to go to the directional pads to be able to do this Yeat!!!
Giambi
combo move hmm, and I just get so scared. What is it I get so scared. Oh, oh?
ay yeaa...
goobe, please I don't know ohh that built that over there, okay, okay?
Don't need to go back there again, because I highly doubt there's going to be what I need
But your actual anyway if I can get some Wampa fruit I guess
Nice nice. Nice. Nice. Nice. Just as what I wanted
ohh I hate that they're oh God
- ah there's a checkpoint yay, and a life almost does it they know?
Almost is the thing no, oh
almost as if the KNOW, oh ahh (screaming internal in head)
ah ah, yeah, yeah
Nooo!!! I was on it. It screwed me. It slid screwed me.
Okay, oh, oh yes, okay, not gonna screw me this time are ya
Got ya, bitch. Oh my God. I can't see what I'm doing. Oh, I get you guys doin' in the bonus Zone. Oh
Okay, here. We go. Fuck this  gooo, gooo, ahh, goo
Gooo...Oh, no, come on ( Mark is raging on inside)
At least you get to retry that one as many times as you want awfully convenient of them
ahhh goo goo goo.. yay yay yay yay? Yay? Hello good bye all right
Made some lives if I've got a plenty of lives I've got a plenty I've got a plenty of other lives
uh-huh? Yeah do tell wait am I supposed to go down it looks like I'm supposed to go down
I'm Gonna go down
Well I saw it was obvious it was right there  How it that not I'm supposed to go down.
oh swear...
Okay, well there goes okay? My immunity. Just got used up in blasting those guys into hell. Oh
oh ah ah goooeo ,gooeo, goeoo. I  don't know  where I'm going
oh yeah oh yeah
This game is going to give me an aneurysm an aneurysm. Oh now. Oh now. I can go down.
I don't know what happened there, but I got really confused and scared oh
Yeah, oh, yeah
Hai-yah! Hai-yah! Hai-yah!
Heh- [wails] NOOOOO!
...frick. Ugh, I must be getting close to the end though
Okay
Go, GUH! Okay. hurr, hur hurr
Oh no! Why was...It  the directional.....It was the d-d-irectional
I d-did the-! Beh- ARGH!
I'm starting to lose it, I think
geoo, I'm very clearly only using the directional
Great. Why would I want to blow those why would I want to take the I'm taking the risk here? I go. I don't
[shrieks]
everything's fine
Boom okay. I don't know why I did that, but I did it
Yeah, okay, and I have another checkpoint place. That would be lovely if you could do that deliver it right to my face
Please oh no no, no I asked for a checkpoint not this I like that. Oh my God, okay
We're fine one. Slot that they're in my panic
Why are you doing this?
Okay
cool Pinstripe, le Port Or O
T porter odd, I don't know oh
Hi, okay. Well anyway. I did that oh my God I
I did I don't even care. I don't care six hey. That's not that bad. That's okay
I think it was the boxes on the way back from the little sippy  stepy thing, but anyway
Huh, I think that's a good enough point to break this episode of crash, Bandicoot
So I'm going to be playing through the full of this, and I'm gonna do it all today
So in the next episode you'll see me progressively losing my mind more and more because I'm not Gonna
Take a break until I beat this so you can look forward to that
Split in  episodes throughout this life of mine, so yeah, so thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this I know I did
"Question mark" let me know how I did in the comments below
And thanks again. And as always I will see you in the next video... Buh-bye!!!!